[Applause]  prey is set in the 1700s 300 years  before the first movie  and it is this creature's first time on  earth trying to find the most worthy  opponent  the predator's hunting is just for sport  he's here to compete in the game and  he's here to win  yeah then  [Music]  no  he has us  [Music]  this predator he's very primal he's  going back to basics he's coming for us  he's pretty fierce  he's always looking for a fight  but when he looks for his prey he always  goes after the alpha  he hunts with earlier versions of  weapons we had seen before like the net  device  and there's the weapons that we have  seen  the shield that unfurls and then the cut  clamp  this is going to be a fight to the end  to see who is the predator here  who is the prey  you